hey guys dr berg here i want to share some real
interesting things about wheatgrass that you've
probably never heard before okay now the first
question is what is wheatgrass well it's not the
grass that grows in your backyard okay it actually
comes from the wheat plant so wheatgrass is baby
wheat okay it's the stuff that they eventually
can turn into flour that they that you can buy
at the grocery store that they make bread and
pasta and cereal and donuts and cookies right
that's what they make and they sell white
bread and wheat bread the whole thing okay
so that's the flour this is
made from the grain or the seed
the seed is what has the gluten in it okay
that's what creates a lot of digestive issues
and people have inflammation from it
they get all sorts of digestive damaging
damage now this is a baby wheatgrass plant
this is at the stage where it's well before
the seeds are going to grow so you have no gluten
in this stage whatsoever so there's no gluten in
wheatgrass juice powder only in the actual seed
that's grounded into flour okay so that's one
thing that people have a confusion about but
the cycle of a plant when you have a seed or
a grain it grows into this plant this is the
reason why they capture the wheat grass is that
this is the peak nutrition for phytonutrients and
nutrition right when it gets about this size about
four four to six inches that's when you have the
most nutrition in the cycle of growing wheat okay
so the next thing i want to talk about is what's
the difference between the powder okay wheatgrass
powder and wheatgrass juice powder okay real big
difference very interesting number one is that
if you take one of these grass i don't know if
you've ever done this and you chewed on some grass
what happens you can actually crunch it there's
some crunchiness what is that crunchiness
you're basically grinding with your teeth
this fiber and there's little pockets of
of wheatgrass that's in there a juice i'm sorry
and the juice is being released with all the
nutrition so all their nutrition is inside little
pockets so it's like little air bubbles it's very
similar to bubble wrap okay so i'm sorry to chew
this bubble wrap i'm not going to chew it you
could actually start to hear the crunching so when
you're chewing this you're actually releasing the
nutrition okay so the problem is that wheatgrass
is mostly 99.99 of its fiber it's a cellulose
this fiber does not digest in a human digestive
tract a cow has a very specific enzyme to break
down this grass we do not so when you buy
wheatgrass powder you're basically buying
the fiber mostly because when you consume it you
don't have the enzyme to extract the nutrition
and it's captured in there it's kind of like
eating hay and that's really what hay does
hay is like dried out grass and you feed it to you
know horses and things like that so there's not
nearly the amount of nutrition in chlorophyll
in the grass powder and the wheatgrass juice
powder there is no fiber okay it's all
nutrition it's extracted and it's preserved
so it's a hundred percent absorbable okay so
that would be the one difference now it takes
this entire entire tray of wheatgrass to
make one heaping teaspoon of this stuff
okay so i'll show you so this right here is
equivalent to this entire tray without the fiber
so it's super concentrated it's like over 2 000
percent more concentrated okay so this is like 25
this is 58 cents and the reason we're able
to do that is because we do this in massive
quantities so the difference is this is mainly
fiber this is more nutrition and this is a lot
more convenient because the amount of effort
it would take to juice this with the juicer
and then clean it oh my gosh going to the
store buying the wheatgrass juice incredibly
not very convenient okay so anyway okay so those
three very unique things about the wheatgrass that
we have that i want to share with you the most
amazing thing is how it's grown we basically
take seeds we take wheat berries we take the seed
of the wheat and we grow them in late fall okay
so the snow comes it covers them and it
doesn't actually become this high until may
so that's six months it's sitting in the
earth and what is it doing it's growing roots
so the specific type of wheatgrass that we grow
has a root structure that digs deep into the earth
pulling all the nutrition up into
that plant so that's number one
this stuff is grown within six to ten days
look at this this root structure it's like
it's just like basically fiber there's no root
structure and a lot of times wheatgrass from the
healthy store that grows mold well this stuff
is very clean because the nutrition protects it
against the molds and the viruses and the bacteria
and insects that whole thing that's what really
see a weak plant will be susceptible to bugs and
microbes even if there's a vitamin deficiency
so we don't have to worry about a vitamin
deficiency with this so we have a combination
of the processing of the seed secondly where
it's grown it's grown in an ancient seabed
what does that mean it's an old ocean floor okay
what's significant about that is that there's all
these trace minerals in there there's like 93
trace minerals those are the minerals that are
pulled into the root structure so you're getting
a product that's so super enhanced with all of
the minerals like this does not have the trace
minerals this does okay so we have how it's grown
we also have where it's grown on and lastly and
most importantly converting this grass into this
powder is very very unique so the company
that i work with use this process called
bioactive dehydration okay it's a very unique
patented process where they basically take
the juice of this and within minutes
turn into powder using very low heats
so when they juice it the problem is that all the
enzymes all the oils the fat soluble vitamins the
essential fatty acids in this grass the vitamin
e complexes are very fragile to oxygen and heat
so number one we have to do this fast so it's
quickly converted into a powder within minutes
under low heat nothing above 106 degrees and even
for one minute so we have a it's only heated for
um like 106 degrees for one minute and then
the temperature goes down and it turns into a
powder so what you're getting right here is a raw
live product in a powdered form when it becomes a
powder the enzymes are preserved and protected so
all you have to do is add water to this so i'll
show you to activate the enzymes so it's basically
alive so i'm going to take this put a teaspoon
now one one thing with my other wheatgrass
juice powder and i didn't talk about this
is that um i would say put it in a glass and stir
it there's a lot of clumping that occurs with that
so i'm gonna highly recommend you get a shaker
bottle okay tighten it up and you shake it
this gets 100 of it in the form that's really
smooth with no clumping okay look at this thing
this is like liquid health liquid life
so then you can actually drink this
and it's very very refreshing okay so number one
the seeds are grown for six months in the soil
which allows for the root structure secondly you
have where it's grown on ancient seabeds third you
have the bioactive dehydration where we convert
this into this within minutes so as to protect
the enzymes and all the other delicate nutrition
okay so there's a couple other unique benefits
what i did with this wheatgrass is i added uh
what's called kamut wheatgrass what is kamut
wheatgrass well there's a kind of a story a
background story in 1949 this air man was in
egypt and apparently he was visiting
the the pyramids and uh he came back
uh with some wheat berries that he found in
some tomb of some pharaoh okay and he shipped
them back to montana where they started to grow
them basically they found the ancient wheat berry
and that's why they call it sometimes king tut's
wheat and that's what kamut is when other people
take kamu to make flour and make bread even though
it has gluten because it's a seed they don't seem
to have the inflammation or the digestive issues
so that's very interesting that the ancient grain
doesn't create the reaction like you would get
you know at your local store but what they did
is they the company i work with basically take
the seed of kamut and it grows it same soil same
process but we added 25 percent commute into this
and the reason why i wanted to do that is because
kamut has some unique health additional health
back factors number one it has tons of selenium
selenium is great for the thyroid in converting t4
into t3 especially if someone has hashimoto's okay
secondly it's really uh loaded with more protein
okay and a lot of other phytonutrients so i kind
of spiked this even more than my other version
which is kind of a plain version with more
nutrition then we added an organic natural lemon
flavor with a hint of stevia so when you consume
this it's it just it's delicious okay it's like
a lemon drink it doesn't taste bad at all uh and
it's like quite amazing okay so to make it easier
to drink and then two other things number one
it's very convenient you don't have to get a
juicer you just take this around take a teaspoon
teaspoon stick it in here it has a little scooper
in there as well get a shaker bottle that's going
to be important shake it up and drink it some
people do it in the morning some people do at
night some people do it morning and night if you
take one serving it'll last you 60 days okay the
cost per serving is 58 cents this is 25 okay so
it's it's a we're able to bring the cost down
because we get it in bulk i have to order a year
in advance of this stuff because how it's seasonal
and they have to grow it i can't just order it
tomorrow i have to wait and then i have to make
sure that's why i keep running out of this stuff
because it's such a great product people and then
i have to wait until it comes back okay and i
put a link in the description box so you can
get more information about this and then send
me your comments thank you so much for watching
hey guys thank you so much for watching please
click the subscribe button and
i will see you in the next video